[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lectures we had been
discussing a number of uh
different displacement potentials ending
with the complicated looking
padkovich noible representation now the
stated motivation was that
this babkkovich noible representation
would help us
in solving uh something very important
in 3d elasticity which is the kelvins
problem
now before we can actually launch into
the kelvins problem
we need to discuss a couple of
mathematical precursors
okay so the first mathematical precursor
will be
in relation to the uh poisson's equation
uh
and of course uh the motivation for
discussing this
is that uh if you remember in the
papkowitch novel representation
uh the the whole idea was to
reduce the problem to a uh to the
solution
of poisons equation so it makes sense to
to discuss the solution of poisons
equation
in general please note that this
discussion in relation to the poisonous
equation is very very general
uh doesn't only relate to the
to the solution of the kelvins problem
wherever you have poisonous equation
uh this discussion is relevant
okay so the general way we can represent
a positive equation
is like this we have the laplacian
operator operating on
some scalar some vector any tensor field
but
to keep things specific uh and without
complicating the notation too much we'll
just say that
this laplacian operator is operating on
a vector
okay so but this could easily be a
scalar it could be a second order tensor
right now this thing is going to be
equal to
some function some given function
f okay and this also is a vector
now the question is what is the solution
of this
without worrying about the boundary
conditions or anything uh
we will have to worry about the boundary
conditions in relation to specific
problems
but in general do we have a solution for
this so the answer is yes we do have a
solution for this
at least the particular solution
so when i say particular solution i
basically mean it in the sense
of when you when as uh
as first year engineering uh students
we studied the solution of differential
equations we studied
them as composed of two parts the the
homogeneous part and
the particular integral of the
particular solution it is that
particular solution i am referring to
here
so the particular solution to this
poisson's equation is given by this
[Music]
the superscript p represents the
particular solution
and this
functional dependence on the x vector
it represents basically the notion
how the particular solution will
depend on the various positions
that we are sitting at okay so
this thing is going to be equal to
minus 1 by 4 pi integration
over the entire volume of consideration
small affected so this is this
[Music]
so let me discuss what i mean here
okay so this is rather complicated
looking
but let us just break it down up so see
this entire integration is taking place
with respect to a dummy variable
for the integration purpose which is
this
x dash okay it is affected of course but
this is
this is the prime variable this is not
this variable this x vector is only
present
in the denominator here okay you
understand that this
entire integration is with respect to
this x dash
vector the cube here represents that
this is
basically a volume integral okay so
uh possibly some of you are more
familiar with the
representation that we put three
integral signs here for a volume
integral
if you want you can do that what i
basically mean is that i am integrating
this over the entire volume of
concern okay
this x vector it represents
that whatever the result of this
integration is
it will be a function of this x vector
because after this integration with
respect to the x dash has been done
please note that we know the form of
this f vector because it is given to us
that is the that is the load or the
source
uh driving
the uh driving the distribution of
whatever this f has to be
so so we know this we can
we can carry out this integration uh
either analytically or numerically
various methods are there
and we end up with a functional with an
answer which
depends solely on x dash okay
so sorry on on x expect on x vector
not on x dash not on the x dash uh
so this is it so this is the particular
solution now the total solution
so the complete solution
[Music]
it will be a summation
of this particular solution and
the homogeneous part
[Music]
so the homogeneous part will correspond
to the solution of this
by putting this thing to be equal to 0
okay so f h
is basically the solution to this part
[Music]
okay whatever the solution of this this
is this all right
so this is exactly following the notion
that we learned in our first engineering
mathematics
okay now uh
uh the immediate question is how do we
even arrive at this thing
okay so i'm not going to uh go into the
details of this
uh because that is almost a chapter
in applied mathematics in itself uh and
we have to let me just tell you that we
have to go down
the route of using uh something called
the green's function there is an entire
very mature theory
associated with these green functions
uh for the purpose of our course on
applied elasticity we do not have to
know those things we only have to know
that the particular solution
comes out to be of this form however for
those of you are
interested uh you can just google it or
i can maybe share some learning
materials
later on associated with green's
function uh but
i'm repeating for the purpose of applied
elasticity we do not need to go down
uh learning those green functions the
theory of those green functions we just
have to utilize this
particular form all right the next thing
uh that we that we need to know
is something called the 3d dirac delta
function
okay so you are all familiar with the
dirac delta function
uh so although we refer to it as a
function it is actually
a distribution but with certain caveats
we can call it a function uh strictly
speaking it is not a function
so the 3d dirac delta
now all of you are familiar with the
simple direct delta
from our engineering mathematics so if
you have
a thing like this
this delta x
is defined in such a fashion that
this is equal to 0
for all x which is
not zero okay
and at x there is a spike
okay so uh i i hope you all
remember this from your undergraduate
engineering mathematics
now the only thing that we'll do here
in connection with our discussion of the
3d direct delta
is to just make this dependence not on x
but on
an x vector that's it and we'll say that
this is true for all x vector
not equal to zero and you understand
that this is actually
like a zero vector now
uh you have to understand this that uh
this is i mean this this this kind of uh
of a discussion it is pertinent
like whatever is present inside these
brackets
as long as that is not equal to zero for
example
we could have a situation like this that
delta uh x vector minus psi
vector so in that case this is going to
be
equal to 0 as long as
our x is not equal to sign
you have to understand in this fashion
and this will carry
a lot of importance in our subsequent
discussions
now uh these are two apparently
unrelated things
but uh you understand that we are
discussing these
in connection uh or or as mathematical
precursors to the kelvins problem
so now what i will do is
i'll i'll discuss
[Music]
an example of a poisonous equation
involving this kind of a 3d dirac delta
so let me do this in the next page
okay so suppose uh so you consider this
kind of a poisons equation
[Music]
okay so instead of the f as the small f
vector which was present in the general
theory in the earlier page
we have made it to be like this where
this a vector is some constant
okay it has three components but it's a
constant vector
it's not dependent on x or anything
okay now
uh we also must
must understand that this psi vector
it is the position vector of a
certain fixed point in space okay so
this
psi vector is
is the position vector
of a fixed point in space
or of a fixed point okay
so the particular solution to this
okay the particular solution to this
[Music]
is given by
[Music]
so let us check in the previous page
what we had written
there was a y minus 1 by 4 pi here
okay so this minus 1 by 4 pi we'll write
it exactly in this fashion only
replacing this f vectored x dash
by by what we have in the present case
so
this is minus 1 by 4 pi
just substituting the affected
by this thing and please note
that when we had written this
this equation uh we
we basically meant it uh
that this f was dependent on the x
vector and this
f was dependent on the x vector
okay so we replace that x vector by the
dummy index here
by the dummy variable here x dash so
that's exactly the same thing we are
going to do here so whatever was
x in the original equation we are going
to replace it
by this x dash the psi is the position
vector of a specific point we don't
touch it
and in the denominator you note that
we had written it like x vector minus x
vector dash so this x vector is the x
vector that is
relevant to the original equation and
this is the dummy variable that we have
introduced so that so that so this
denominator it simply does not change
okay there is no story of this psi here
and we have to finish it up by writing
it properly
that the integration is with respect to
the
x dash now uh
as we have already mentioned this a
vector is some constant
so it can very well come out of the
integration
[Music]
now we are left with
this thing inside
[Music]
now what do we do
well we can go back to this
discussion of the dirac delta and write
a special property
of this direct delta so just like our
in our previous discussion of the
chronicle delta we had mentioned that it
has this very special
power uh which you have come across so
often
uh you use so often in your in the
solutions of various problems
and proves the substitution power so
also
this kind of a of a dirac delta has has
something
uh which can be referred to as the
filtering property
so suppose you have a situation like
this
that you have a vector t and
we have an integration like this suppose
so this is x dash
and we have the direct delta like this
[Music]
or we can we can use this to be some
some other some other variable
doesn't matter let's say
this is this is anything else let's say
this is i
and suppose again we are integrating
over the entire volume
the x dash being the dummy variable for
the integration purpose
and we are carrying out this integration
so what is the result of this
now this is quite complicated looking
but the good news is
because of this filtering property this
has a very simple result
that this is simply
[Music]
this okay so
i believe uh some of you will be able to
relate this thing but with what you
studied in connection with the
one-dimensional
uh direct delta which you learn learned
in your undergraduate engineering
mathematics
one very important point to note here is
that
for this formula to hold it
you must must ensure that this i
is lying very much within the volume
okay so this is
uh this is true only if psi is lying
within the volume of concern so if
you're carrying out this integration
over a certain volume
this i point must lie within the volume
if it is outside the volume
then this result is equal to zero and
this is very special case that if
suppose this is lying on the volume on
the surface of this volume
then you'll have to write this with a
half okay so that's how just how this
definition works
but for our present purposes we don't
need all of those things
now we only need the case where design
is very much lying within the volume and
the result is like this
now you compare this thing so this this
general result
from this filtering property of the
direct delta with what we have here
so let me keep that thing at the top of
the screen
uh so you just compare so we again have
an integration so let's this is about
integration over a certain volume and
you note
that just like we had this uh dirac
delta this 3d direct delta with the x
dash
minus i so also we have this thing okay
and this t vector x dash
that is present here so this is like a 1
by
x magnitude of x minus
x dash that is present here and the only
thing that happened
was that whatever was present in the
form of this
x dash that got substituted by this very
specific point
so the exact same thing is going to
happen here so the result of this thing
will be simply that the dirac delta
it will unleash its filtering property
on this function 1 by magnitude of x
vector minus x
vector dash and we will end up with
1 by x vector minus
psi vector
please note that this should make sense
to you
because this thing here is a function of
x x vector okay so this right hand side
also is a function of x vector because
you see this a vector is a constant 4 pi
suppose just a constant
thing the psi vector uh
it is a vector no doubt but it's a very
specific point okay you're choosing a
certain point
so uh so this does not have any
dependence on x so this is the only
dependence on x so the right hand side
is a function of x the left hand side as
you were expecting it should be a
function of x
so it's it's all nice and consistent and
this is the answer
to the particular solution okay so
there will be a different story
associated with the homogeneous part of
this equation
and it will have connections with the
with what boundary conditions
are relevant for that particular problem
but you will see that
when we actually start our discussion of
the
the actual solution of the kelvins
problem this
particular example that we have seen
here
just as an application of what we were
discussing in the previous page
it will become immediately relevant so
on that note i will
i'll end this lecture here thank you
very much